also müssen ich bin meinem text backup
es geht sondern willkommen zu einer
neuen folge mit xtext wir haben die
kollegen von max gemacht
und das ist auch okay ich hab ich hab
ich ja weg locken
ich muss also habe ich direkt auf den
weg
ich werde jetzt mal was zu kaufen
es geht nicht wie mach ich dass die
politik dieses geschmacks wenn du
irgendwie nicht genug veranschlagt ist
aber ich will mein handicap gerade noch
hatte ich muss kurz ganz professionell
immer schreiben
halter dieses -technologie dich gibt's
nicht ich muss dringend weg von diesen
winter leiter ihr werdet doch ihre ich
habe übrigens bogen da kommt eine heute
schlag was da für geräusche
ich hab' ich will dieses diesen diese
runde einfach blind also ich kenne
keinen ab dieses resort pack davon noch
nicht gespielt und ich erst mal wenn ich
getroffen
der hat übrigens 9 kanal ich kann euch
mal die beschreibung packen also falls
sie die menschen kennenlernen wollte
diesen text
hat dann link in der beschreibung weil
ich immer das beste schwer etwas gibt
das beste vom besten leute kost fünf
gold alter asozial junge das ist ein
abgesagtes comeback
oder wenn du loslegst was ich will das
unbedingt machen
warte warte warte unsere besten cover
ich bin selber und da bist du aber glück
gehabt sonst wäre ich mich mit meinen
kram traffic sieht richtig gut aus schon
ja du hast ja auch neue sounds hinaus
sollte aber du bist hast du siehst du so
eingestellt dass der krieg schon aber
was ist das für eine art rache oder
einfach der junge diese geräusche
nein sie da kommt wieder her alter die
spiele ich hab noch nirgendwo angreifen
dann irgendwo angreifen als ich und ich
bin ja einfach so beim zweiten jahr an
greifen schild ich war nur froh mein
schwert 8 nico mit komik macht den
blogger sitzen die die letzten jahre
älter
wir müssen sie verarschen noch langsam
langsam
in diese bereiche zu machen
ja ich gebe ihnen so den hit unter dach
geräumt alter kleiner basar leute dann
aber dieser kurzen aber heftigen
lauffläche und ich hab leider schon
bauchschmerzen behinderten text ich habe
nicht gelernt einfach eine ansage machen
das ist eine zahl wie viele vielleicht
heftig
500 likes bei 500 likes gibt es das zum
download als 400 leuten seien 500 leute
wenn ihr vielleicht schafft dann gebe
ich euch dieses behinderte lacht
flashback zum download fees volt
preislich ist auch cool auf jeden fall
könnt ihr gerne eine bewertung da lassen
sich gefangen hat und den raul abstecken
der das gemacht hat
ich werde spontan irgendwie so der
gedanke also falls ihr euch den typus
die kinder aber ich finde es lustig
denke mit ihnen gerne mal abstecken
es liegt in der beschreibung und dann
sehen wir zum nächsten video wieder haut
rein macht es gut